yo today i'm bringing you guys another
style video
and it's an interesting one because i'm
talking about
seven ways that guys are still dressing
raw
let's not waste any more time let's get
into it
[Music]
now let me just make this very clear at
the start of the video we are all
different people we are from different
cultures from
different countries and we have
different styles
so please understand that in this video
i'll be talking
about my own perception my own point of
view
of style that's based on years of
modeling experience
based on my own culture and just based
on myself
my character who i am as a person and
what i like so
if i say anything that you don't agree
with then that's cool
because we're different and we have
different styles and nobody can really
tell you
what you should wear but with that being
said also know
that other people will make assumptions
about you
based on the way that you dress based on
the way that you present yourself
now with that said let's start with the
first style mistake
some guys make
daddy shoes i just don't get i don't
understand guys with dirty shoes
i mean listen your shoes talk a lot
louder
than your words than your mouth because
it tells people a lot about your
character
i mean you can't pitch up for that first
date or
job interview with dirty shoes or
anywhere else for that matter
if you keep wearing your dirty shoes
what do you think people are going to
think
well they're going to think you are
dirty because your shoes are dirty all
the time
so you look kind of lazy and sleazy
because you don't take care of your own
things
look have some pride in your own
belongings take care of it clean it
and have some pride in the way that you
represent
yourself
big jeans never wear jeans that are too
big for you
or any other pants for that matter why
because number one you look sloppy to
other people not
professional number two when jeans are
too big for you
you usually make the belt tighter right
so it won't fall off
but then you get this extra material
here in the front
and that might give people the wrong
impression when they see it
so how do you determine the right size
for you
well you test it take two fingers and
push it between your hip and your
waistband
if it fits it's the right size if
there's more space
it's too big and if you can't fit in
your two fingers
it's too small
the hanging jeans i just can't get over
this one
it's 20 21 already and this style is way
in the past
it's really so disrespectful because
no one wants to see your underwear brand
or your bum hanging out all the time
and there's almost no style out there
like this one that shows people that you
are
kind of lazy and arrogant and walking
around
like you just don't care about anything
and anyone
but yourself
big brand names look
for some reason some guys think if they
wear big
brands it will make other people like
them more
for some reason and they want to show it
off look i'm wearing cool brands look at
me
it doesn't make you a better person you
don't suddenly become
a cooler guy you're still you with or
without
branded names now look i've worked for
some big brands
as a model let me tell you you should
never
buy it just for the name when you go and
you buy clothing
only buy it for the right combination of
style
quality comfort and price
those four things need to go together in
a perfect
balance these big brands out there that
just hike up the prices
not because of the quality but because
of the name
of the brand now another very important
reason why you should not
wear big branded clothing is because
they use a very clever
marketing strategy by printing those
names big on your clothing and you
walk around with it so you're a walking
advertisement
for them did they pay you did you get
money for it
no so why advertise for them unless
you really like the brand then it's
probably fine
sandals with socks look i know
some guys they like it
in some cultures they're used to it and
that's fine but for me
i just don't get it because for me
personally it looks terrible
and also it defeats the purpose it
defeats the purpose of
wearing sandals especially in summer
sandals are made so that your feet can
get air when it's hot
but now you go and you put socks on them
socks
are made for shoes not sandals
pants that are too tight look slim fit
pants
are cool they're great i love them
especially if you go and tailor them to
fit with your unique
legs right because everybody's legs are
different
but when they're too tight oh my
goodness
it looks terrible and i can feel your
pain especially in the crotch area
no just no guys
[Music]
huge belt buckles i mean there was a
time
when it was in that was a long time ago
so unless you're a cowboy then
don't do it if you are a cowboy then
that's cool you go for it you do your
thing
but if not maybe it's time you change
your style
now just because you've watched all the
way to the end i've got a bonus tip for
you
matching the wrong colors look you gotta
you gotta learn the basics of color
matching
if you just wear the same color for your
whole outfit
it's not going to look great well unless
it's neutral colors like black for
example now i've got a whole video for
you
that will teach you the basics of color
matching it's definitely going to help
you out you can watch it after this
video
now when it comes to style always
remember this
even if you have the most expensive
clothing in the world
and the best style you'll still look
terrible
if you wear it with a arrogant puffed up
personality
the best thing that you can wear is
confidence
with humbleness now always remember
life is short so don't waste it i'll see
you next video
cheers